in the late 90s sarah michelle gellar
was in command of both the big and small
screens but nowadays she seems to have
been relegated to the world of TV
animation voiceovers he has a look at
why Hollywood won't cast Sarah Michelle
Gellar anymore fright casting Gellar
might have gotten a start on a soap
opera swans crossing and all my children
but she really made her name as a scream
queen just as she stepped into the title
role in TV's Buffy the Vampire Slayer
she also appeared in the 1997
cheese-tastic teen thrillers I know what
you did last summer and screamed to
almost all of us silver screen successes
since then can neatly fit into that same
horror box like 2004 stir grudge it's
2006 sequel and the return from the same
year even her family film work in the
live-action scooby-doo flicks only
boosted her scary movie reputation a
reputation she now can't escape bad box
office Gellar gained instant popularity
thanks to buffy and her fun / affair but
her efforts outside the fiesta fear have
failed to lift off a supernatural
rom-com simply irresistible what's a
flat ol flop and nobody saw her weird
crime drama Harvard man no one saw her
part of the viral porn star in the drama
D Southland Tales either or her
psychological drama
Veronica decides to die she's proven she
can put buttons and seats whenever
someone's chasing her with a knife but
viewers just haven't shown up to check
out other offerings killed by critics
galas movies have received almost
universal disapproval from reviewers
even those few films audiences did come
out for simply irresistible for instance
earned an embarrassing 13 percent rating
on Rotten Tomatoes and the return was
Massacre to earning just 16% even the
grudge was mostly disliked and the
sequel was a magnet for critical
thrashing when you look at that resume
it almost oscillate like career suicide
small screen struggles Buffy was a fan
frenzied highlight of Geller's career so
once a movie star status proved to be
DOA she returned to TV to see if she
might be able to find favor with at home
audiences again and she got our answer
nope her crime drama ringer which
featured Gellar as a pair of twins on
the run from scary near duels bombs of
critics and audiences alike and failed
to earn a second season
then her network comedy show the crazy
ones which featured her alongside the
late great Robin Williams also got the
axe after a single season
ouch low profile her off screen exploits
haven't done much to boost her profile
either her long live marriage to fellow
90s hottie Freddie Prinze jr. has
produced two children and zero drama
meanwhile her social media feed losses
with total proud mom gush like a zillion
pics of her kids and snaps of her
family's culinary adventures it's all
fantastic for our personal well-being
but that kind of wild and crazy life
doesn't exactly keep up in the headlines
you like a like a smoker ball yeah
there's nothing in vocal victory she's
got a face for the cameras no doubt but
post Buffy Geller's had better responses
to her voice work than her screen
appearances she's done almost a decade's
worth of audio character work for
Cartoon Network's Robot Chicken and
you've heard her other places too like
The Simpsons
TMNT and even video games like Call of
Duty
let's puree some zombies most recently
she and Prince have tapped into the nerd
domain with their voice roles and Star
Wars rebels and seemed to be drumming up
some solid fanfare as a result of their
show it's not over yet one thing that
could turn this all around is if the
Cruel Intentions TV sequel finally takes
flight audiences nostalgic for Kathryn
special kind of deviance might respond
if and when the show is ever made
it wasn't mentioned on the 4 2016 order
sheets for any networks but Gellar said
the delays were only due to the fact
that they want to get it right the road
is taking a little longer than normal
but we we've all been adamant that to do
it we have to do it right and we have to
do it you know it
it's a naughty show and you have to you
know pay homage to what it is and you
have to make sure that it all fits
let's hope they do thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what kind of rolls you'd like to
see sarah michelle gellar take on next